I love the idea of someone having a
dream this show has changed my career
path I mean in so many ways they have a
sparkle in their eyes it's just the best
star quality I don't know if you got it
or you don't
we've just never seen that sort of move
before and that's what I find so
exciting I get so excited to see who's
you know gonna surprise me who's gonna
make me scream bloody murder you know
and somebody will it's the season 15
auditions of So You Think You Can Dance
[Music]
dancers from all walks of life showed up
for a chance at the top prize like 29
year old Jade Jackson who you may
remember as Miss estranja from RuPaul's
Drag Race I'm really here today to prove
that drag is not like a gimmick or a
joke it's an actual real art form I
think a win for me is a win for my
community and that's why so you think it
in should crown mama what is it about
you that makes you special and different
I was born with an orthopedic disorder
called fibula him Amelia and I was
missing a lot of the bones ligaments in
my left lower leg so when I was 10
months old they amputated it and I've
been learning to walk with a prosthesis
how to prosthesis ever since overcoming
these challenges and coming here today
what does that mean to you I hope that I
can touch other people's lives and
inspire anyone with any kind of
disability to just keep doing what you
love 23 year old Alexis Gilbert made it
to the top 40 last season now she's back
this time vying for a shot at the number
one spot I'd like really dig deep and
like make new moves find out different
ways to bring my jazz in and still be me
is there a judge that means a lot to you
that you would love to get some positive
praise from vanessa hudgens I grew up
watching High School Musical oh and
she's got real Montez so it would just
be like astonishing it's what inspires
you to get out there everyday and help
these dancers achieve their dreams I
know what it feels like to start from
nowhere and the fact that I get to be a
person to give these guys a chance it's
just like my heart kind of melts which
he's a bigger inspiration for me he
never stopped like this that's very
inspirational it's grown in that that
motivates and motivates us to keep to
keep going
that's the power of what this show can
do is create dancers like it like you
knew Gene Kelly like you knew Fred
Astaire now we know Lex in Samoa we know
Allison Holker we know Travis Wall we
know Benji Schwimmer
you know those names make me scream it's
gonna make me cry but I you can't you
get a reaction that you cannot control I
mean I've sobbed them for certain
numbers embarrassingly you know but it's
like I have no idea I this
and just affected me but usually it's
something unbelievable three words to
describe season 15 season 15 woo
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]